here we go with another one we have
stockfish versus berserk so this was the
uh computer chess championship
bullet so this was the bullet semifinal
let's get into the game here we go
stockfish goes with e4 move one very
nice and then we got c5 you know it's
going to be sharp so then after knight
f3 d6 d4 takes takes and knight f6 are
we going to see a knight or knight c3
defends the pawn and a6 we got the
knight or sicilian which line let's see
f4 it's already starting to get
aggressive right now very aggressive
stuff with the intention to play e5 and
actually when you play f4 fast like this
not only is it unorthodox so something
that you can use against you know some
of your own opponents that may not study
this line because it's not the main line
night or something that's not played as
much could give you some advantages out
of the opening but this is an engine
right and engines playing each other
here in a bullet game here they're used
to this they know what to do playing the
correct move which is e5 striking in the
center this is actual theory and after
knight f3 knight d7 is stillbook move
here knight d7 very good stuff defending
the e5 pawn we're still going to play b5
later still play night or fashion and
kind of neutralize the fact that white's
playing super aggressive but we're still
going to do what we want to do in the
night or actually says black a4 stopping
b5 right makes total sense and now can
you guess the next move for black here
black to move what would you do in this
position
after the a4 move guys after a4 happens
can you believe d5 happened on the board
yes
d5 pawn to d5
looks like a blunder it's about to get
wild here but in fact this is actually
very crazy honestly but it's complicated
and it makes complications inside of the
position d5 what it's about the main
idea is the bishop the main idea is give
me bishop on this diagonal here while
making huge complications in the center
and white's like okay let's go for it
knight takes d5 show me what you got big
fella bishop c5 pawn sacrifice i am now
up upon this is a bullet game not one
minute in fact time control here was two
minutes one second increment so not real
bullet bullet like 100 one minute bullet
chest but this one is still very fast
bishop to c5 after a bishop c5 and uh
knight takes d5 bishop c5 f takes e5 we
take and actually capture um so we can
capture the knight knight takes a knight
g4 looks good but it actually doesn't
work at all due to this bishop g5 move
which looks really cool we can go bishop
h4 and x in many cases this is engine
work this is about to get very sharp if
you think this is sharp and crazy
looking
don't go anywhere just sit right here
okay watch this so um after uh knight 2x
knight takes e4 so we gotta stop and
look and see what's going on here i mean
this this this position is berserk ish
you know because of the name of the
engine and stockfish is playing here i
mean definitely does not
does not uh disappoint when it comes to
berserk d5 and knight takes e4 what is
going on bishop f2 knight f2 this this
this is strange right you could
definitely mess this up after knight
takes e4 white just says bishop d3 come
on with it i don't believe you and
knight f2 does happen it's on the board
there it is he called your blood what
are you going to do about it what are
you you're you're obviously you're
forked here your queen and your rook are
both hanging you need to do something
about it so what do you do can you find
the move
most of you raise your hand all of you
prank queen e2 queen d2 or the moves
right queen e2 queen d2 or bishop to g5
the best defense is offense
so bishop to g5 attacking the queen
there very nice move here so if you take
mine i take yours and then knight c7 may
be jumping in there as well your knights
hanging and it's messy very messy
position bishop to g5 queen to a5 check
says oh oh your queen's hanging so
obviously we just defended queen to d2
and then knight takes d3 so we're
getting rid of the bishop pair that
white had black has a nice bishop pair
to still try to boast here and see if we
can use this both kings are in the
center lots of chess left especially if
the queen's trade knight c7 almost
mating luckily we have a square but we
are able to pick up some material open
position things could get crazy knight
takes d3 c takes d3 and then this next
move here from black well first off
let's check out what's going on white's
up a pawn in this position um black and
white have the same amount of pieces but
queen there's some tensions on the queen
here obviously the queen actually for
black has no squares so there this is
like a forced trade unless you find
something like bishop f2 whoa where did
that come from i didn't even see this
move isn't this just
stupid right the queen's defended it i
mean what does he do it does he want to
trade this way why would he just give me
a piece i'm going to take with my king
can't take him my queen obviously
because i was pinned here so i'm going
to take her my king and laugh with you
until he plays queen takes d5 and you
forget that your knight in the center of
the board was hanging whoa what a move
now yes okay we still probably take
white here if you're looking at this
especially if you didn't see this move
coming you might be a little bit shocked
and like the after effect whoa i didn't
even see bishop f2 what is this idea
about but after the settles you see
white still has an open file king is a
little weird but it can't be exploited
and maybe bring the rook here and do a
hand castle on the other side as well
you know black still needs to castle or
do something with his king or whatever
we're expecting and maybe we can do some
sacrifices of our own and get this thing
going after queen takes the b5 rook h to
e1 doing exactly maybe tucking the king
something like that black castling here
and rook to e4 rook lift very nice guys
there's a lot of moves here too as well
58 moves so let's move through some more
chess here rookie 4 queen e6 getting um
out of the way of kind of like rook d4
looked kind of annoying maybe
centralizing maybe you want to play f6
later right there's many things you can
do queen g6 right it's just a good move
get the queen out of the center because
it can be attacked queen e6 rook a to e1
doubling the rooks makes total sense
here why wouldn't you if you can double
the rooks most likely you can in many
cases and you should rook 80 e1 rook e8
putting pressure on the weak pawn can be
defended very easily here and and
miraculously engines say that this is
equal right equal somehow equal position
rookie either rook 801 rookie 8 now of
course i would take white a little bit
more because of the space but virtually
equal with best play rook e8 after the
rookie eight move there's a pressure on
the e5 pawn and white plays rook to d4
which i thought was very very clever
here with rook to d6 intentions and
after the night moves to f8 because
black has problems where with
development i am not fully developed my
pieces aren't off the back rank and even
though i don't have a light square
bishop as white which would give me
better attacking chances i still have
attacking chances very good because i
have a central pawn number one that
actually is passed they pass deep on i
have the rooks that are very active my
king isn't the best but you can't get to
it all my pieces are kind of doing stuff
around the center there's only a matter
of time it feels like before black's
position collapses due to lack of
coordination so after knight f8 rook to
d6 attacking the queen queen to a2 i
mean this queen all the way out here by
herself everybody back home just kind of
watching queen a2 knight to d4 and he's
like you know what i'm just going to
pick it up thank you appreciate it
thanks for a little gumdrop here pieces
aren't developed when pieces are
developed and yours are and you have all
your pieces developed usually this is
when tactics start to happen in this
position it is right to move what do you
do right now
here it is guys here's the move all
right so we look around the board
everything's all spaced up feeling like
we got some space here maybe we took the
king right king g1 maybe hand castle
maybe rook lift the other room something
like that maybe queen f4 maybe try to
slide this way or you play
bishop f6 open up shop
open up the shop see who is home right
now it just says this is equal and you
know it's a problem when you're sacking
a piece and the engine says it's equal
bishop f6 is a super strong move here
with the intentions of just literally
blasting opening the king a5 berserk
didn't want any of that action and in
fact rick a6 is the intention to try to
help defend rook to e4 right with
intentions of knight f5 knight e6 knight
somewhere somewhere besides c maybe even
c6 but besides b5 ricky for queen back
to a2 how many times have we moved this
queen right piece of steel here oh my
goodness queen a2 and here it is bishop
takes g7 it's about to go down king
takes g7 and what do you think the next
move is guys right check here check
there right which which one do you think
it is is it is it one of these checks
what is the next move here let me get
the arrows here so you can look at this
white super what do you do next how do
you finish the attack is it completely
winning is it completely losing what do
you do here
what do you do here okay in fact
stockfish actually as we as we we we go
back and look at this stockfish says
queen g5 is the best move but in this
game h4 was the main the move uh that
was played which is still just as good
in a way h4 is pretty good um we're
going for this attack here this was
playable even queen h6 was a little
playable too as well but h4 you're
getting more pieces into the game can't
go rick g4 don't block with your face on
national television here bishop takes g4
it doesn't work h4 knight to g6 and um
um yeah so he's trying to try to defend
queen g5 is not mating so he plays h5 to
kick the knight
he thought this game got crazy right
because after rook a6 nice defense he's
saying okay cool you know what you're
attacking me what's the best way to get
rid of pieces that are attacking you you
trade them very easy way for anyone to
understand this i'm being attacked trade
the pieces attacking me very simple rook
a6 get rid of this trade everything off
i took this pawn you know maybe i maybe
i could be better here right so white
understands this and in fact i mean this
right here this is why you should be
doing your puzzle rush every day this is
insane to find this move right here
white to move what do you play in this
position now already i mean it's just
chaos in this position i do not blame
you for not finding this move because
you're not going to find this move is
what do you think it is why it's a move
you're not finding this there's just no
way you're going to find this
white's move
here it is right this move right here is
ridiculous
e6 are you kidding me e6 the rook is
hanging d6 i had to look at this i
looked at this for like five minutes
after e6 rook d6 on just this position
spinning five minutes right with
analysis looking at this this is insane
rook the rook is actually hanging we
gotta see what happens if he takes it
and he didn't take it he did not take it
here it says i mean e6 here like had to
be using some type of engine
okay so after e6 here right e6 what a
move rook takes d6
is not a move because of knight at five
very nice king h8 and queen c3 check and
mating
mating oh thank you these are the engine
moves you know how the engine does right
the engine move made in four because you
give up all your pieces so okay all
right uh that nice beautiful line there
so
i mean with this still being a bullet
game by the way rook takes bishop takes
e6 being played seeing that that was
made no matter what that was nasty we
didn't like that so after bishop e6
queen to c3 and lines up on him and says
i'm going there anyway and have a nice
day right after queen is c3 black goes
with king 286 sidestepping all of the
action all on that diagonal they're not
having none of that and then white plays
knight to e6 boom taking another piece
setting up stuff like close to
anastasia's mates kind of
i mean it smells like that but not
really i mean you do have these checks
too as well with mating ideas everywhere
especially after king takes h5 rook
takes a6 getting rid of that happy to
trade some pieces says black queen to d2
and king to g7 all right what do we do
now okay that's kind of settled a little
bit black's playing pretty accurately
even in this position but very very nice
to see we sacrificed the material we
weren't able to really convert just yet
still down material we are down a full
night in fact we sacked and still didn't
get it back yet so it's a white to move
here what would you do in this position
there it is we didn't mate right we did
not checkmate taking tonight we're going
to just lose the rook here so we just
trade look rook takes rook e takes um
takes e6 so if if we take this rook
obviously we're going to be up material
so we take this rook instead f takes e6
still being up a piece momentarily
because after rook d7 king f6
now we can take back and now boom does
settles all this craziness happens we're
down upon but black's king is in the
middle of the street it feels like and
the queen is where far away too far away
now okay like to move in this position
guys would you make this next move let's
see if you're gonna find it would you
make this next move this requires some
very serious calculations maybe pause
the video
and come back to play it but uh we're
not gonna sit here and wait for you to
come back 30 minutes later so definitely
pause the video and try to get this um
this this one here
okay so after king takes g6 move um here
the move here is queen to f4 are you
kidding me allowing the check what check
queen takes b2 allowing queen takes b2
for the queen to get back and defend are
you kid what
how why would you do this because it's
the only one the best way to win another
route was queen d1 which is the same
idea getting the queen active but giving
up this pawn with check that's the
hardest thing to do is giving up things
with check right just to win the game so
after queen f4 queen takes b2 check king
g3 tuck and roll here no way to actually
uh force a trade queen goes back to f6
and here we go the decisive technique
the decisive
sequence of moves can you find it can
you find the sequence that wins the game
here white to move here it is nice
sequence starting with queen to g4 here
it is very beautiful queen g5 is what
happened in the game but that of course
if you've been doing your puzzle rush we
know how that's going to end immediately
if you could see it with g7 and this
game is going to be quick after that but
let's take a look at what happens on
king h6 which is a move that many people
would be like well i know that so let me
sidestep you but then the next move here
will be queen h3 which is now
threatening whoa queen h7 if you go back
to the original square so you're
probably going to go king g5 which makes
sense queen h4 check you go back i'm
going to take here again which we're
going to look at that and if king f5
okay cool we can go queen g4 queen f4
allows king g6 but then we'll just
repeat but don't repeat three times
because you get a draw so we got queen
g4 king here and then queen e4 is
checkmate walk them down a little line
there a little pick and roll a little
shake and bake right and uh and got him
in the checkmate there and then it came
to g6 the original boom hitting and then
rook g7 hitting there looks disgusting
where i have to give the queen up anyway
so it didn't matter after queen to g5
here rook to g7 game was over and then
the rest here is history the rest is
just easy clockwork cleaning up shop
right as we watch the rest of these
moves but this attack was brilliant
hopefully you guys learned from this
attack here as we see him clean up shop
here finally picked off the rook
was able to clean many ways to win here
obviously but uh this is in checkmate
with a double queen checkmate here from
stockfish very very very nasty game
nasty attack hopefully you love this one
and if you love this one make sure you
check the other ones in the videos
provided after this one so we'll see you
guys on the next video
[Music]
you